klaus rinke et les équipes du centre de
création contemporaine olivier debré met
la dernière main à l'instrumentarium une
oeuvre que l'artiste allemand avait déjà
présenté en 1985 au centre pompidou à
paris
la composition réactiver dans la nef du
ccco des mélanges les hôtes et grand
fleuve d'europe du tage au danube ou du
rhin à la loire une oeuvre comme une
méditation sur l'art la culture et la
géopolitique liées à l'europe et à l'eau
les ethnies qui commence à se séparer et
sont tout le monde pense de sortir de
l'europe comme les anglais je voulais
aussi aller en angleterre
a nice on voulait ramener la tamise non
jeudi laisse les et sont partis ils ont
pu la danse et ses les rivières d'europe
je ramais l'europe moi je suis un vrai
européen
je suis né en 39 en allemagne pendant 30
ans klaus rinke a enseigné à la
kunstakademie de düsseldorf où il a
côtoyé des artistes tels que yves klein
ou daniel buren
la deuxième partie de l'exposition au
chômage cette génération à travers leurs
oeuvres
la kunstakademie était très important
pour la ville il n'ya pas une autre
ville dans le monde entier tout les
russes et les noms des artistes de
l'académie
même le beau y aura maintenant c'est aux
fps vous faut alors la ville était très
ouvert pour pour là tout de suite après
guerre l'école c'est la premier col
d'ares qui s'est ouvert et tout le monde
venait de l'est partout pour étudier
alors ça c'est de cette première
génération
mémoire vivante de ce chaudron
artistique que fut la kunstakademie
klaus rinke est intarissable sur le
sujet mais les oeuvres racontent aussi
cette période et bien plus encore
l'instrumentarium et düsseldorf mon
amour sont à voir jusqu'au 1er avril
[Musique]